youtube star savannah lebron reveals her
oldest daughter everly's father tommy
smith has died he was only 29.
[Music]
savannah shared this sweet photo of the
two and wrote in the caption quote our
hearts are incredibly heavy as we
process the loss of everly's dad tommy
he loved everly immensely as we navigate
through this difficult time we kindly
ask for privacy so that our family may
continue to love on ev pray and grieve
with her your prayers for everly are so
very appreciated an official cause of
death for tommy hasn't been released
savannah's been open about starting a
relationship with tommy when they were
teens at 19 she became pregnant with
everly my mom just started crying and
she goes well we're gonna love this
little baby like
i don't
basically i thought she was gonna kill
me for being pregnant at 19 but she
totally
was opposite and was so supportive and
even though she told me i was done for
getting pregnant pregnant at so young
which of course i was wasn't being too
smart but i got the best little miracle
baby ever out of it and i wouldn't
change it for a thing but after
welcoming their little girl savannah and
tommy's relationship didn't last he's
still everly's dad um
we we get along great now um i mean
co-parenting is hard and sometimes we
bonk heads but
um we make it work and i never ever hold
the past against him at all so savannah
raised her daughter as a single mother
through the years until she met her now
husband colebrand who's been in everly's
life since she was three years old
okay it's morning
it's getting a little crazy in this
house because it's everything's first
day of school
and despite things not working out with
tommy and savannah he did have a close
relationship with her daughter
[Music]
it's amazing for him to be in her life
still we're we're great now we co-parent
and we're good as friends
[Music]